for both of you uh there's been at least
four documentaries i think uh how does
that fit into
the decision decision process to take on
the the subject
and the approach funnily enough when i
optioned the book way back when in 2004
i
was introduced to the book i and i had
no idea that the documentaries existed
and i'll never forget the day after i
optioned the book that i learned
the documentaries existed
and um so i was kind of you know like
taken aback a little bit but my
introduction to the to the story was
through the book
and i'll never forget the day that i
put the two documentaries in and watch
them back to back for about four
straight hours and just sat there with
my jaw dropped
and because i don't know if any of you
have seen the documentaries but they're
quite um
it's quite a colorful cast of characters
and
it
it
both intrigued me further but it also
was very interesting because to be quite
honest i had
a reaction to damien
that i think was probably
i could understand
why the town
was able to be manipulated
and and and whipped up into this frenzy
because damien
is
a very interesting very bright
um and and complicated
unique
personality very strong personality and
so i it kind of set me on a journey
um
of doing even more due diligence on on
the project and and and kind of just
reassuring myself that that it was the
right thing to make the film
um and uh but that's that's the impact
it had
it's interesting that the the
documentaries actually did really focus
on
a tiny slice of the story and and the
book
um
was really a much bigger picture um
and uh going in we knew that the world
had sort of seen these documentaries so
we were going to have to find new angles
and new information and and there is a
lot of
new information in this film that that
never came out in any of those
documentaries and
we just thought it was important to show
other sides to this story because it's
such a complex story that has so many
different people involved we chose two
characters that had very little
spotlight on them prior to us making
this film we had um
a couple of directors that
were attached well one in particular was
attached prior to adam
and um
but then adam was really
when we found adam it kind of unlocked
the
the the whole
project and and thrust it immediately
forward and i think that i think with
every film it's funny you go through all
these journeys but i think you always
end up exactly where you're supposed to
end up well reece was always
our first choice and we were very
fortunate to get her
and um
colin i'm sorry i mean well colin and
adam had worked together once before and
i think um adam adam really felt the
same thing about colin which is that he
was his first choice and
um they had a working relationship and
we just felt that you know ron lax
is is a real person who unfortunately
recently passed away actually since we
completed the film
um but uh he was this kind of
strong quiet individual i mean liz liz
had a you know a close relationship with
him and knew knew him quite well and we
really felt that that colin
embodied that the spirit of this of this
individual he did and ron it was funny
we showed the film to ron and his wife
and
and uh it was not conscious on colin's
part at all
um but
his wife felt that ron had i mean that
colin had absolutely just captured ron
down to his walk but that was all um
very organic it was not you know a
conscious mimicry or anything we've
become so accustomed to seeing southern
courtrooms i was thinking as i was
watching the film you know there's
legacy all the way back clearly to kill
a mockingbird and movies like that but
also the grisham
based films uh
and uh do you think that that heritage
is a a challenge for a movie like that
like this or an opportunity because
people understand the rhythms and the
and the
the tropes of it or do you think that
you kind of have to
separate from all the melodrama
well i think that um one thing that we
were very conscious of just in terms of
it
taking place in the south
and
this being a story about real people
from the south
we were
we were very conscious about wanting to
be certain that we portrayed them
not stereotypically in any way which is
obviously
a kind of pitfall that you can
fall into and i think that adam did a
fabulous job with that and all of our
actors we were all very conscious of
that and
i'm really proud of the way it turned
out from that from that aspect jason
baldwin one of the west memphis three
is an executive producer um with us
again liz liz really spent a lot of time
um
meeting and knowing these characters
like pam hobbs and and jason and other
you know players who were involved in
the case and so
jason was
he had always really liked the book and
and in fact met his fiancee
through the author of the book um and so
uh
he he came on board as one of our
executive producers so we had
really
created jessie
as did as a jesse miss kelly um and pam
hobbs was very involved um
ron lax so we really had a great uh
uh cadre of people to advise us because
they were the the real people who were
involved in and and jason baldwin uh
came to the set a few days and in fact
he came to the set when we were filming
the courtroom sequences and he just said
it was the most surreal thing for him to
sort of go back and see himself be be
sentenced to life in prison once again
in this courtroom um but we again we
felt really blessed to have people such
as himself so closely attached to our
project adam also
made a decision early on
because this was a story that had been
told through some documentaries so
people had seen
some of the real places and some of the
real people
you know he decided that he wasn't
trying to replicate everything he was
really trying to you know find the
essence of the story and tell it in his
own way and in the courtroom is is just
a good example of that which is that the
actual courtroom was a very modern
boring courtroom but you know we found
this location that was kind of more of a
classic southern
old courtroom uh that had great light
coming through the windows and that kind
of thing and
again he said that was that was the
right thing to do because he wasn't
trying to simply
recreate every last detail that people
had already seen in the documentaries oh
that's interesting because because you
could really go sort of the in cold
blood route where you know you're trying
to do as as close to journalism as
possible or mississippi burning where
you kind of take the the mythology
and
in in contrast to what adam said our our
writers
actually determined early on that they
really wanted to
try to be as close as possible to the
story and to the facts and so
the the script itself is very very
factual and was based on a lot of core
transcripts and so there's it's not like
there's a lot of drop you know of
fictionalizing of the story but in the
way adam wanted to approach it again he
wasn't just trying to make another
documentary